es ist kein geheimnis dass man auf
youtube und allgemein im internet mit
social media eine menge geld aber wie
viel ist es in meinem fall konkret in
meinem fall bezogen aufs jahr 20 21
genau das werde ich euch in diesem video
aufschlüsseln ich wünsche euch viel spaß
im jahr 20 21 war ich irgendwo zwischen
230 und 380.000 abonnenten das also im
hinterkopf behalten und außerdem ist
vielleicht auch gut zu wissen was auf
meinem hauptkanal circa 30 videos und
auf meinem zweit und dritt kanal namens
des studio insgesamt 130 videos kamen
circa 100 reactions und 30 videos beide
staaten mit den ausgaben kommen ja dann
erzähle ich euch von den einnahmen und
dann gibt es eine gebündelte übersicht
wie viel ich verdient habe wie viel
gewinn war wie viel umsatz ich gemacht
habe und so weiter
[Musik]
wir starten erst mal mit den ausgaben
ich werde euch die zahlen immer gerundet
vorlesen oder darüber sprechen im video
seht ihr sie aber in ihrer vollen summe
eingeblendet im januar waren es 12.000
euro februar 33.000 mehr als 16.000
april 24.000 bei 18.000 juni 15.000 juli
21.000 august 25.000 september 26.000
oktober 33.000 november 22.000 und im
dezember sage und schreibe
56.000 euro ausgaben das ganze führt im
jahr 20 21 zu ausgaben von
304.000 792 euro und 62 cent aber wie
sind diese ausgaben die zustande
gekommen da habe ich alles in kategorien
aufgeteilt das macht ein bisschen
einfacher zu verstehen die kategorien
sind equipment requisiten alles was ich
für videos brauche reisen das studio an
sich ist ein eigener kostenpunkt
gehälter klamotten werde ich gleich auch
noch mal erklären mein auto laufenden
kosten und andere wir starten direkt mit
equipment es ist offensichtlich ich habe
eine teure kamera wir brauchen teufels
licht der kater braucht und vernünftigen
rechner ich brauche einen vernünftigen
rechner handy streaming rechner
bildschirme und so weiter es ist
tatsächlich dieses jahr ein bisschen
mehr geworden auch einfach aus dem grund
dass werdet ihr auch bei anderen stellen
merken dieses jahr war für mich ein ganz
besonderes jahr weil ich das erste mal
die möglichkeit hatte wirklich in meinem
unternehmen in mich selber zu
investieren deswegen sind an equipment
47.000 euro dieses jahr ausgibt das ist
eine menge geld aber das wird sich
hoffentlich über die nächsten jahre
auszahlen weil wir jetzt hoffentlich
voraussichtlich erst mal ein paar jahre
uhr haben werden keine neue kamera
kaufen müssen keine neuen rechner kein
neues licht und so weiter trotz alledem
ist es so aufgeschlüsselt dann doch
schon immer erschreckend zu sehen wie
viel geld wirklich raus gegangen ist
aber es ist ja auch ein bisschen was
rein gekommen und dazu später mehr
erstmal zu ausgaben für requisiten
darunter zähle ich gewinne für das
studio gewinnern wenn es um im game ging
und jemand geld gewonnen hat dann ist
das in dieser kategorie mit geschenke
verstecken miete von beispielsweise dem
kino equipment für das kino video und so
weiter alles was ich im video extra
gebraucht habe und mir dazu kaufen oder
mieten muss auch hier
1498 euro dafür im letzten jahr drauf
gegangen das liegt aber eben auch daran
dass sich ungerne abstriche bei meinen
videos mache und einfach bereit bin das
geld dafür auszugeben ich möchte nicht
nur solche lava videos machen wie jetzt
sondern ein großteil meiner videos und
das wofür ihr mich vermutlich am meisten
mögen videospielen bisschen aufwendiger
sind und wo ich besondere sachen dazu
tour besondere sachen mache und das
kostet meistens eine menge geld das ist
wahrscheinlich eine lehre die ich dieses
jahr wirklich zu spüren bekommen habe
man bekommt nichts geschenkt das auch
selbst als influenza nicht auch wenn das
von außen immer so ein bisschen subjekt
als könnten würden in florenz einfach
alles geschenkt bekommen ich weiß nicht
wie es bei den anderen aussieht bei mir
ist es in den meisten fällen so dass
sich die sachen selber bezahlen müssen
und nur hier und da vielleicht mal wird
angeboten bekomme was ich dann natürlich
auch dankend annehmen aber die meisten
sachen gerade für videos bezahle ich
selber man könnte jetzt auch denken dass
hotels welche die auch für die videos
brauche schon in requisiten kategorie
gefallen ist das ist nicht so dafür habe
ich eine eigene kategorie namens reisen
die mich im letzten jahr 24 1789 euro
gekostet hat business class flüge züge
ihr habt das alles gesehen ich bin
dreimal nach istanbul geflogen für
klamotten produktion ich war für videos
in frankreich die neue online gekommen
sind weil ich mich verletzt habe ich war
schon ziemlich viel unterwegs und das
ganze
sind fast 25.000 euro dazu zählt nicht
mein auto und auch nicht die laufenden
kosten meines autos mit dem ich dieses
jahr auch über 25.000 kilometer gefahren
bin gerade mal neun monaten nur für
videos dazukommen gleich auch noch mal
eine eigene kategorie mir fehlt so ein
bisschen die luft wenn ich die ganzen
beträge sehe studio ihr wisst alle worum
es geht eines meiner größten projekte
des letzten jahres der folgende betrag
ist ohne gehälter wir haben 20 21 37
1340 euro für das trio ausgegeben 37.000
euro nur für studio miete an und abreise
licht miete miete der person die das
licht bedient und so weit das war schon
super riesig aber ich habe mich von
vornherein nicht dafür entschieden das
komplett selber zu finanzieren weil ich
niemanden drin haben wollte der mir
darin spricht er sich eine firma mit
reingenommen die anteile an das studio
hat es vielleicht interessenskonflikte
geben und ich hätte nicht so frei
entscheiden können was ich machen will
und deswegen habe ich das komplett aus
eigener tasche bezahlt und das ganze
waren eben knapp 40.000 euro kommen wir
zu gehältern darunter ist leo mein kater
der mich seit jetzt knapp über einem
halben jahr unterstützt der auch an der
studie mitgearbeitet hat bei dir dass du
dir gab es aber noch zwei andere cutter
die wir freelance mäßig mit reingeholt
haben für gehälter und rechnungen in
diese richtung also leute die an dem
projekt mitgearbeitet haben sind knapp
60.000 euro um genau zu sein 59
1463 euro aufgegangen das ganze hat
komplett seine berechtigung ich glaube
alle wurden gut bezahlt und das soll
auch weiterhin so sein dass es keinen
punkt an dem ich sparen möchte bei allen
projekten an denen ich fest mit leuten
zusammenarbeite also jetzt nicht
freelance mäßig sondern die wirklich mit
mir ein projekt gegründet haben oder
fest bei mir angestellt sind jeder
dieser leute ist umsatzmäßig oder gewinn
mäßig beteiligt jeder das soll auch so
bleiben das möchte ich weiter fortführen
das finde ich super weil wenn die leute
mehr oder besser arbeiten dann sollen
sie dafür auch belohnt werden dass wir
nicht sehr gut und dass es keinen punkt
an dem ich im nächsten jahr sparen
klamotten 33 1450 euro dieses jahr bin
ich in vorleistung gegangen um klamotten
zu produzieren die hoffentlich nächstes
jahr herauskommen da freue ich mich sehr
drauf also dieses jahr schon die kosten
gehabt nächstes jahr wenn die dann erst
verkauft aber das waren knapp 34.000
euro weiter geht es mit meinem auto das
mittlerweile völlig demoliert ist an
jeder stelle 25 tausend kilometer bin
ich gefahren das musste versichert
werden was müsste geladen werden das
laden ist nicht wie viele von euch
denken komplett kostenlos nicht hatte
das glück über affiliate kram von tesla
ein paar freikilometer bekommen zu haben
das war aber hat aber nicht meine
kompletten kilometer abgedeckt inklusive
des kaufpreises des namens der
versicherung hat mich das im letzten
jahr 55 1731 euro gekostet steuer mäßig
ist nicht so dass das komplett in einem
jahr prämiert das baby gone hinweg die
kosten hat es trotzdem letztes jahr
55.000 euro
laufende kosten kosten die jeden monat
wiederkommen so was wie büro
handyverträge versicherungen abos
plugins also die ganzen programme wollen
bezahlt werden die wir jeden tag
benutzen da gibt es so ein paar dienste
die wir definitiv buch müssen die will
buchen wollen die wir haben und da ist
eben auch das büro drin dafür haben wir
letztes jahr 17 1682 euro bezahlt im
nächsten jahr wird das deutlich mehr
denn haben ein deutlich größeres büro
angemietet das video dazu findet ihr
hier oben und glücklicherweise jetzt zum
allerletzten punkt andere das sind
irgendwelche kleinen beträge die ich
bezahlt habe um irgendwas bei amazon zu
bestellen um irgend jemandem der uns
beraten hat der uns geholfen hat ein zug
von a nach b zu buchen oder sachen die
ich einfach nicht 100 prozent einer
kategorie zuordnen konnte waren knapp
10.000 euro mit
9481 insgesamt wieder der inso gesagt
haben wird kosten von 304.000 euro das
hört sich erst mal richtig schlecht an
aber wir haben natürlich auch ein
bisschen was an geld eingenommen
unglücklicherweise mehr eingenommen als
wir ausgegeben haben
und vorweg bevor jetzt an die einnahmen
gehen er hat schon gemerkt es war ein
super hohe ausgaben das geht nur wenn
man das geld auch in irgendeiner weise
eingenommen hat ich weiß es komplett
unkonventionell dass es sich eben den
anfang 20 youtube ins internet stellt
und darüber redet wie 100.000
hunderttausende von euro rein und raus
gegangen ist das ist kein maßstab an dem
man sich messen sollte oder irgendwas
ich weiß nicht so richtig was ich dazu
sagen soll es ist völlig verrückt mir
ist das bewusst und ich rede da so nicht
darüber weil ich das gerade eben alles
in irgendwelchen excel-tabellen
aufgelistet habe und so ist es völlig
verrückt jetzt aber zu den einnahmen
tatsächlich sollte das ein bisschen
schneller gehen denn ich habe im prinzip
drei wichtige einnahmequelle das ist
youtube mit adsense placement bridge und
vielleicht noch so ein bisschen aktien
das habt ihr aber vermutlich alle anfang
des jahres mitbekommen wir starten mit
youtube adsense drei kanäle dave the
studio und meinen zwei kanal mit
jacksons auf dem dave kanal mein
hauptkanal habe ich 63
1500 euro mit adsense verdient werbung
die davor und in der mitte der videos
läuft ihr wisst alle wie das
funktioniert friedrich mein zweiter
kanal wo ich in parow jacksons hoch
gelernt habe sind 25.000 350 euro herum
gekommen und bis studio
10.300 rund 70 euro was insgesamt
einnahmen von 99.000 219 euro sind
fritsch eine plattform die ich hier und
da mal bespielt habe ich bin kein
streamer ich bin youtuber und das steht
bei mir an allererster stelle weswegen
tritt letztes jahr vielleicht ein
bisschen zu kurz kamen ich aber trotzdem
gemacht habe insgesamt sind dabei
rumgekommen 8200 euro knapp davon fehlen
aber 6500 euro irgendwie die auszahlung
verpackt hat die sind irgendwo in der
schwebe und ich bin im austausch mit dem
support dass das geld so schnell wie es
geht bei mir ankommt aber das sind eben
auch sachen die hier und da passieren
und es läuft nicht immer reibungslos
aktien kein richtiger teil von meinem
youtube einnahmen er so geld bei youtube
verdienen dann versteuern dann privat
damit in aktien investieren das habe ich
jetzt hier gemacht jetzt alle
mitbekommen 16.000 euro in gamestop
investiert dabei sind 58.000 euro rum
gekommen - den einsatz von 16.000 euro
untersteuern franzen reingewinn von
30.000 auch wenn es jetzt nicht richtig
zu den youtube einnahmen zählt wollte
ich einfach nochmal mit aufnehmen weil
es eben auch einnahmen aus 20 21 waren
das ganze führt uns zudem wahrscheinlich
interessantesten teil dem teil mit dem
ich am meisten geld verdient habe und
das ist wie es vermutlich alle vermuten
könnte placement auf dem haupt 2 kanal
und auf das studio auf install alles das
gebündelte ich mal relativ wenig auf
install der absolute bärenanteil davon
ist von meinem hauptkanal und quasi der
wirkliche in nebra dafür dass ich die
sachen so umsetzen kann nichts machen
dabei sind im jahr 20 21
274 1295 euro rum gekommen was völlig
verrückt ist bei leuten die gaming
videos oder daily uploads oder so
bringen es ist häufig so dass adsense
der teil ist der am meisten geld
einspielt bei mir ist es so dass bei
einem video die woche oder vielleicht
zwei videos die woche ist es so dass ich
quasi das ganze nur so weiter ausbauen
kann weil es werbepartner gibt die
bereit sind bei mir zu werben also dass
ich die möglichkeit habe das komplette
geld von dem placement zu nehmen davon
artikel zu kaufen und die zu verstecken
ist nur möglich bei ist diese firma gibt
die bei mir werden möchte und weil es
davor schon eine menge firmen gab die
mir quasi ermöglichen ein video zu
machen an dem ich keinen gewinn machen
das hat sich über die zeit so sehr
aufgebaut das es uns ermöglicht haben so
viel geld für equipment auszubilden dass
ich diese luxus hotels flüge und so
weiter testen sachen die mir eine menge
spaß machen das ist nicht normal das ist
mir bewusst aber ich bin extrem dankbar
dafür deswegen ein dickes danke an jede
firma die 20 21 mir so viel vertraut hat
dass ich das machen kann und ich hoffe
das 24 22 hatten sich wieder
zusammenkommen damit ich mehr tolle und
große video macht
[Musik]
das heißt das ganze aber jetzt konkret
wie viel es reingekommen ist
rausgegangen wie viel es dabei übrig
geblieben wie mache ich das mit gehalt
und allgemein wie sieht so aus insgesamt
300 und
4792 euro ausgaben
381 1710 euro einnahmen ergibt einen
gewinn von 76
1918 euro und 13 cent das ist relativ
wenig für so einen großen umsatz den ich
gemacht habe aber wie gerade eben schon
gesagt das waren ja in dem wir uns
leisten konnten war sie was wir wollten
wir das gemacht haben und ich super
happy damit bin weil wir quasi für jahre
hoffentlich set sind und jetzt einfach
nur arbeiten können ohne uns darum
kümmern zu müssen dass wir irgendwas
weiter ausbauen dass irgendjemand kein
richtiges equipment hat wir können uns
voll auf die arbeit fokussieren 76.000
euro ist eine menge kohle das geld wird
versteuert und was davon übrig bleibt
ist dann für mich für mich privat ich
habe mir im letzten jahr 1500 euro lohn
im monat ausgezahlt das werde ich
vorerst so weitermachen damit das geld
in der firma bleibt und wir quasi
komplett freestyle videos für euch
produzieren können ich hoffe ihr habt
einen kleinen einblick in besseren
einblick darin bekommen können wie das
ganze ist wenn man vielleicht noch nicht
so super lang auf youtube dabei ist in
der zeit ist wo man investieren muss und
quasi komplette freiheit in der arbeit
hat aber im privaten keine komplette
freiheit hat und sich vielleicht da ein
bisschen einschränkt damit dass
arbeitstechnisch so weitergehen wie man
sich das vorstellen kann ich bin auf
jeden fall super happy jedem von euch
sehr dankbar dass ich das so machen kann
dass ich quasi selber wirtschaften kann
dass ich ein kleines unternehmen
aufbauen kann jobs schaffen kann und
umsetzen kann was auch immer ich möchte
also vielen dank auf eine menge tolle
videos 2022 vergessen ist das video zu
leiten und den kanal zu abonnieren wenn
ihr keine folgende videos verpassen
wollte was gut
[Applaus]